first I would like to introduce author
Marjorie Liu who tonight will be leading
a conversation Marjorie is an
accomplished author of over 20 novels
and a prolific comic book author as well
most recently making the news or we have
some fans that's great for monstrous the
Eisner and Hugo award-winning graphic
novels that have found a home on the New
York Times bestseller list and like our
main speaker tonight she is also a
Marvel Comics alum like mine Marvel
having written for the dark Wolverine
series Black Widow
x-23 han solo x-men and others her
portrayals of LGBTQ characters have won
our accolades as well the MIT community
first got to know Margery here in
comparative Media Studies in writing
where we have had the pleasure of
hosting her comic books writing class so
if you're interested in that hopefully
next fall it will be offered again I
also forgot did I introduce myself
tonight's featured guest is Brian
Michael Bendis Brian is a five-time
Eisner winner which is the Eisner Awards
are like the Oscars of the comics
industry the arc of his career is
interesting he initially supported as
comics habit where the gig as an
illustrator for his hometown newspaper
after stints at smaller comics such as
image where he won his first Eisner
Brian was hired by Marvel Comics in 2000
to launch its ultimate spider-man series
at Marvel he would go on to write or
collaborate on some of the biggest steps
forward in contemporary comics for
example in 2011 he and Sarah Pacelli
created the character of Miles Morales
an afro Latino teenager as a new
spider-man who is I saw a preview for a
movie come animated
coming out I hope you're getting a piece
of that but in any rate Bryan created or
developed many characters for Marvel he
has served as an author on everything
from daredevil to Jessica Jones the
Avengers guardians of the galaxy and an
incredible 100 issue run for x-men
before moving last year to write for DC
Comics even people at MIT who don't
follow comics knew that the invincible
Iron Man vol 3 number 7 when Bryan
introduced the character of riri
Williams an MIT student who hacks
together parched poached from campus to
create her own Iron Man suit and thus
creating iron heart a black female
superhero the middle picture by the way
is a artwork that somebody I don't know
who painted in one of our tunnels here
after MIT admissions did a video that
featured her as a character for Pi Day
last year now of course as many of you
know you know that this is the Julius
Schwartz lecture series Julius Schwartz
worked for DC I had one of my colleagues
to say I don't know how you know how it
would feel to have a Marvel person
invited to speak here and then I think
that's why Brian JumpShip and but any
rate as you all know Brian
is now writing for DC and working on the
original superhero a comic book
superhero Superman when I think this
would have been your first work
published with that is that right yeah
as I said this lecture series honors
Julius Schwartz the co-founder of the
first science-fiction fan scene in 1932
and the DC Comics editor that helped
launch the DC side of the Silver Age of
comics seeing the reinvention of
characters such as Batman Superman in
the flash as well as others this event
is supported by a generous gift by
author Neil Gaiman who was our first
schwartz lecture and we are most
grateful to him
previous course lecturers have include
Gaiman and Babylon 5 creator michael
Straczynski and tonight's comparative
Media Studies is happy to add to that
list later and that's what those mics in
the aisle are for alright well I want to
say thank you for doing this Marjorie
before I was interrupted no I I wanted
to tell you that because you know
sometimes people see things like this
they're like oh we know each other like
we would be pals we don't know each
other we have a lot of mutual friends
and Kelly sue has made it very clear
this will be great but I love that I
love that we don't know but I thought
people would like to know that you're
asked you're asking questions you might
not know the answers to as supposed to
okay is it was it pointing the wrong
direction some in sideways all right
okay if you guys can't hear me just
shout just let me know all right it's
good all right okay cool so I thought I
would just start with the beginning
because you've had you've had a long
career you've worked on so many books
and so many different projects in
different mediums and so you know please
forgive this most basic question but why
do you write no I appreciate that that's
actually one of the themes of my life of
the last few years you know why you
spend a lot of time and I'm sure a lot
of you are in the how phase like how do
you do this how and you're so busy with
the how that the Y can fall to the
wayside because the Y is actually a
scarier question it's actually a much
harder question to answer and the answer
is constantly changing and as soon as
you grab the answer it could like jump
out of your hands and become something
else you got to keep chasing it but
because of that and because of the noise
of the world
we live in lately I've seen a lot more
fear-based decisions being made like a
lot of people there they're scared to be
with their truth so they write something
other than they write something they
think that people will like maybe people
will like me if I write this instead of
writing really what's bothering them or
what's you know what's what's inside
inside of them and and one when every
time I ask a question online or I'm
talking in class you when you ask
someone a question about what they want
to write you'll hear the words I'm
afraid I'm fearful I don't want to and
it's always embarrassed themselves or I
guess the little barrier version of like
dropping your pants in public and it's
being ashamed and and when you actually
say well who's done that who who and who
in in literature has expressed their
trueness and embarrassed themselves and
you're like oh I actually can't think of
anybody like you can't think of anybody
they've got laughed out of telling you
know out of being an honest creator so I
want to where I can just bring that up
bring up the why we write and talk about
like why I were where I am into why and
for me it was always about you know I
always talk about writing something that
I would like to buy like I want to make
a comic book that no one else is making
right and for me that was always like a
genre thing like oh I just this cool
idea that I want right and that's where
like powers came from like I want I
wanna I wanna I would love to buy this
book and no one's making of Howard
Chaykin was making this book I would buy
it but he's not so I'm gonna have to go
do it so and that would start me and
then as I would dig into the characters
and I would find these deep emotional
moments and the moments would
subconsciously have similar feels to
them like there would be a frustration
about the world or or an anger about the
world that was coming in through the
characters and then only when I read it
back to myself in in the
new stage in the lettering stage when I
go oh why I'm I'm I'm working on some
stuff right and and I get fearful for
students who are being taught to not
dive in that deeply you know III worry
about it because there's two things
going on as culture number one there's a
lot of there's a lot of shaming online
that I think even if it's not shaming
you directly it makes people feel like
oh I I'll just stay in my little bubble
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna express
myself outwards because there's a lot of
there's a lotta
a lot of people playing whack-a-mole
with people's feelings online right and
and and the other thing I worry that I I
see is that they don't because of the
fear they don't finish what they start
so they'll start a project and then not
completed and that not know why they did
it or what kind of creator they are does
that make sense what I'm saying cuz
because it is it is I see so many people
they they want to show me their first 10
pages of something and I'm like I would
like I would love to see the last 10
pages because I know that's why you
wrote it or that's why you're doing and
if you don't write those last 10 pages
you're never gonna know what the point
of you is so when you first started out
because as I pointed out you were in an
illustrator yeah I was a writer and
illustrator fighter illustrator in
Cleveland newspaper and so when you were
deciding to make that leap into comics
first of all why comics and second of
all how did fear affect you well for
comics for me and I think a lot of you
will know this feeling it's it's a very
unique intimate storytelling experience
you're you're alone in a room and
there's pictures I don't know when
you're with a book it's it's there's
there's a there's a very different but
similar intimacy where you and author
and now creating a visual together right
there's a word picture that you're
creating and I'm gonna put it together
with my values and we're gonna make it
together in comics it's actually white
space in between the panels that we can
all now collaborate together right like
I'm going to
to tell the story but there's a lot of
space in between these images where you
the audience get to fill this in and I
love doing that I absolutely love it and
I love when the creator tries to
completely control all of the
collaboration yet you can't write when
someone's trying to control the pacing
and the timing of it but the audience
still has such a voice also the audience
has such a control over the the tempo
and the and the pace of the page no
matter what you do so I love that as a
reader and I wanted to and then as soon
as you find out it's a job like oh this
is someone there's someone makes a
living doing this well I can't think of
a better way to make a living than that
so it was a very young age I was like 6
or 7 years old when I read my first like
credit box in a comic and I went oh
that's that someone did this then you
get paid all right yeah I was in I was
in very early and I could tell you
what's fascinating to me as the
realities of life set in as the like how
many steps are between me and spider-man
like from I know from my bedroom in
Cleveland that's age 6 to Marvel Comics
there's a million steps
nothing was standing in my way there's
absolute like but not not like I was I
was like ruining people's lives to get
there but I was like you know just
geared towards sometimes when you say
that it sounds like you know you're like
you know Gordon Gekko you're just gonna
destroy everybody to get to your goal
but when I went I met was I was going to
earn my craft to get today and no matter
how hard I found out it was or or what
the odds were and nothing dissuaded me
almost to a pathological now I can laugh
at it but like like David McCall often
will now think back about what you're
just you were just deluded you just did
this went through life just I'm gonna be
spider-man so basically the hunger to
create in this medium burned hotter than
any fear yes yeah I didn't know the fear
and I now feel very lucky that I didn't
know the fear because when I see people
sometimes drowning in it to be honest
with you I'll even see like some of my
students will come to class they have
they have made the effort to get here
which is a big effort and you could see
you know it's just they're terrorized to
just share themselves and and so I feel
lucky that of all the neurotic issues
that I've accumulated over the years
that was never one of them so I it did
help me get to where I need to go so I
do feel as as a creator and a professor
that you know I can tell you yeah you
don't need that fear there's there's
legitimate stuff to be fair afraid of in
this world expressing yourself as that
one of them immediately well you know
I'm sure there are a lot of students
here on campus who would love to take
that leap to becoming a writer to being
in the arts in some way but they just
don't even you know they don't even know
how to get there if it's possible and I
think the great thing about hearing you
speak about this is that the a dream you
can have that you can have the child can
manifest
oh absolutely do this absolutely and so
many of our peers like we all just
that's it we just decided we're gonna do
this and they're like there's no in the
comics who is gonna be well I was gonna
bring a lawyer or in comics it was like
so not like even Charles he was like he
became a lawyer and said yeah I want to
be in comics I this I mean that deep
that deep need to be in comics or to or
film or music or whatever it is everyone
who ends up doing it shares that and so
do you think the comic books connect
more powerfully with readers and other
narrative mediums I do and I do feel
that that's why even with print medium
being in chaos for the last 10 years
comics and graphic novels always are
healthy because and they are it's just
it's just it's a shifting market but it
but the the readers are there and and
the numbers are there and it's because
even with all of the television and
movies and really television and the
amount of comic book television that
there is out there is is the thing
that's most competitive to to us which
is that there's like a thousand episodes
of arrow for free on Netflix right now
that you like like if you need to
scratch that itch it's right there right
where but still people buy the comics
because as cool as those shows aren't as
cool the movies are there's a deep
intimacy
and layers to the narrative in comics
that movies and TV aren't there yet I
think we'll get there because they're
always chasing us but but it and I'm
honestly the thing I was most stunned by
when I saw the first episodes in Jessica
Jones is that they they went they went
there I I was terrified that they
weren't going to I was as I was a
consultant you know and and I was there
and I and I and the consulting is always
writers asking you questions they know
the answers to they just want you to
hear you say it and and when you don't
think it Ingrid it's very funny there's
a lot of quiz about Luke and Jessica and
they wanted my answer and I would have
given a room anyway so yes so but but I
could but someone else is authoring this
this character in this in this medium
and and you have to kind of get Zen
about it and hope for the best so so I
was grateful that that she went where
other shows don't go I was so grateful
because I did not want the other thing
you know but you know it it's our
culture there's a 90% chance it was
gonna be the other thing so be beyond
comprehensive well and you already
mentioned powers but my first
introduction to your work was powers
which is for those of you who aren't
familiar with powers it's about to
deduct detectives who investigate crimes
committed by people with superhuman
abilities is that kind of a yes and what
powers and monstrous have in common is
that we both have titles that everyone
else in comics does oh I can't believe I
would take that oh I hear that so much
about you and we heard that about us the
first two years like everyone at Marvel
there's never been a book called powers
oh my god well I love that book partly
because it was so character driven now
correct me if I'm wrong but soon after
powers was released you started writing
daredevil correct yeah okay and I
started writing powers the year before I
started at Marvel okay and
then ultimate spider-man and daredevil
happen within like a few months of each
other in that even though daredevil came
out first I was writing both at the same
time my dude having been in the
situation of having written three comic
books at once that is a lot oh we used
to see what I'm doing now I genuinely
and other people I I we've lived long
enough to know this they're their
creators that have that can only do one
project and and you should you set uuu
even offered them a variant cover while
in the middle of project they they've
spiral out of control you because they
can't do it well there's other creators
that thrive with multiple projects going
on at once and actually think the
projects get better because all you know
all parts of the brain are being used at
once so that that's where I have found
myself to be the mode but all the
different ways but multiples is where I
thrive no not at all I'm just happy for
that response because it actually made
me think about something else because I
know a while the students here have
they're familiar with having passion
projects but passion can get tiring
sometimes it's also exhausting and so
for you you know you seem to be someone
like you just say like who gets energy
the more you do how do you do you ever
feel like you're running dry no III also
i you know such big things have happened
in my life particularly that just keeps
it keeps things constantly at a level of
energy and good energy and enthusiasm
entertainment that that I want and you
know there's a constant stream of
original art being thrown into my email
but that that's once then once you start
working on multiple projects so like
every day I wake up in Ryan sook and
Ivan rice and David Mack and Michael
Gaydos and and and and Alex believe just
just keep flooding my like I woke up
this morning 245 original pieces of
artwork and I'm so GI can't get out of
here fast enough so start writing right
and and so so that that
the world I live in so it's super super
super exciting
I also not to get too maudlin I know
this it bums people out when you talk
about the last year literally I almost a
year ago this week I both me and my wife
had a near-death experience separate
near-death experiences and so we were we
were faced with the real reality of it
being done it's over and and so and I
end up days where I was blind and I
couldn't write so it was the first time
where I and there were always be days
where no matter how like stressful the
day is I'm gonna go write it out I'm
gonna go just type I don't even know
what I'm gonna write I'm just gonna type
it out and it was always there for me
and then it wasn't right so when it
wasn't there for me for like just for a
few days you go oh no oh oh my lord so
once you get out of a situation like
that you're like you like shot out of a
cannon like you wanna you wanna you know
especially not only that but I was
coming out of it at a time where DC was
literally you know we have whole lines
of material to start producing the DC
was so enthusiastic about us doing so it
was all this opportunity to write and
now and and and having just a memory of
what it feels like not to be able to
keeps you very enthusiastic during the
day so the two things together really uh
and also I get to pay my bills it like
like like when you write like the check
comes when you're done all these things
really really enthusiastic keep writing
know in a time runs out and money I'm a
big fan of deadlines I am I know writers
some tight them I think I us in the
deadline if you embrace them you they
will you they will make you your best
self yeah yeah and I actually in talking
going back to your earlier question that
I never actually answered in the
earliest days of powers or in the early
days in the 90s I when I was a young
creator even at in college I gave myself
deadlines and if I didn't hit my
deadlines I was fired
who lives that nuts and I was like but I
was like steel tired yourself no I would
like literally I'd never miss my
deadline cuz I was very serious
but I would I would take it so seriously
and and like books light like like we
were working on tour so like literally
nine hundred people were buying it
monthly like no one was buying monthly
but I acted if this book doesn't ship
the whole community of Commerce will
collapse and like the whole Ginga of
comments would fall and and I but I
behave that way so by the time I got to
Marvel I was already behaving about like
what now I'm doing spider-man in x-men
and if this doesn't ship yeah something
bad something will happen so I was I had
trained myself well for the job that I
wanted well it's such an important
training because if you miss a deadline
then your writer misses a deadline I
mean your artist miss a deadline your
editor is completely stressed out your
colorist is stressed out everyone is
stressed out down the chain and for a
nice Jewish boy like myself who's raised
on stress and it's perfect all I can
think about is making sure that like our
colorist and really colors really are
the ones that gets a short end of the
stick there the last step of the chain
so if everyone took a week its his week
we stole right so his or her so we want
to make sure that we do that correctly I
think about that all the time if I miss
they miss things also in comics we see
other creators doing this all the time
we see them messing up and you see how
stressful it is to an editor and how it
really can really threaten an editors
job by messing up that way even even
like a brand new creator if you mess up
you really can get your editor fired and
I don't think some creators even think
that way or understand it because that
you know their editor or their boss will
go why where's this book well and it's
one of these things that actually isn't
talked about much I think in our
industry about how just missing a
deadline missing a deadline is so
problematic can be so problematic
because this is a team effort is a
collaboration not just between you and
your artists but between a bunch of
different people who rely on you yeah
and then and then there's the audience
as well like you they've you know
I'm sure some of you have had this
experience where you pre-ordered a book
and well I I mean I recently got an
Amazon update on the book that I ordered
so many years ago that I was like I
really have the Google as make sure the
crater is still with us holy Lord so I
know that feeling I'm sorry but it
happened and but IIIi and I know that
feeling so it's a fan you never want to
do that and you know life can happen
like you know you can you know someone
gets sick or pregnant or you know things
things happen they can delay a book but
so you don't ever want it purposely you
know because of because of red dead
revolution to be the reason the book is
not shipping yeah by the way and and I'm
that is a very funny joke but not to
editors because there's at least one
artist I know who were waiting on
artwork and they literally tweeted 19
hours Spider Man PlayStation they're
like oh dude you can do the 19 hours on
spec just don't tweet it at us don't
tell us that's what you did all day yeah
exactly so what was the transition like
from India to corporate it was were
there any surprises good or bad I lucked
out because I I had a lot of false
starts I had a lot of almost and misses
and I was I was hustling like I was
hustling from the age of six to get yeah
I I already decided Marvel needs me not
not that I need them they need oh my god
I'm gonna I'll fix all their problems I
was incensed by their Raiders of the
Lost Ark adaptation mine would been so
much better like it and it's insane talk
because that's its cause dancing it's
all the great comic artists of all time
that's I was right so I and I've told
I've I've expressed this to Klaus and
I've we've gone through this as creators
he understands there's no personal thing
and yeah and I but I would I would I
would worse and in constantly sitting
portfolio submissions and and and I but
in in in the it's funny how arrogant it
was it's adorable how I was so sure that
one of these is gonna get in and I'm so
glad I went in there was a gung-ho
because every time I got knocked down it
taught me a lesson
and going back to what we're talking
about before about what people are
afraid of Oh failure is so much fun yeah
failure people are terrified of it
they're so deeply terrified of it and I
have failed and I'm talking and I'm not
talking about commercial failure because
that that it really doesn't matter like
I'm talking about creative I'm talking
about like like like owning your moment
in and having a moment and grabbing it
and making the most out of it and and
and and and a lot of that has to do with
getting to your truth going back to our
talking about earlier but the the the
the fear the fear of failure so consumes
people that they they they stop they
just they just freeze and distract
themselves with something else and never
even face the fact that they even not
even knowing that was failure not trying
was yeah yeah and every failure has made
me go oh man that's I feel so much
better about myself having filmed so
desperately and I've done it publicly
and I've done it privately I've done it
you know and I've done it on things that
I've got won awards for that I know I
could do better that I'll never speak up
publicly because I'm not gonna ruin the
book for everybody but I'm like I could
do better and then instead of talking
about it publicly I always hate when
actors do that when they tell you some
movie they hate that movie you don't
have to tell me that just do better in
your next movie just take whatever you
feel and do better than the next time
and so that's what that's what I try to
do so well there's a the novelist John
Scalzi has a saying that I read years
ago and he said I'm too lazy to fail and
I think about that all the time
particularly because writing requires so
much tremendous effort and and you know
you're just working your ass off all the
time and yet failure I feel like doesn't
it doesn't mean what we think of it no
I'm too lazy to fail I might fail at a
book but this idea that I would ever go
back to doing anything else never yeah
absolutely
yeah I mean I think the only time I was
faced with it full blast was I didn't
get into the school of my dreams when I
was in college and my
goes oh so I guess you'd go be a doctor
and I went what like I'm not giving up
what was that like I like it was like
well the only time I remember being
faced as a question and then and then so
it was never gonna be but but going back
to this just the switch to too
mainstream I lucked out because I by the
time I broke in I broken in I had
achieved a couple of things in
independent comics that I didn't think I
was ever going to get like like a nice
or like I didn't think that was going to
happen I wasn't down that track and and
and and so when I when I got into Marvel
I had so many false starts and so many
like dashed and failed and just
completely bizarre submissions that I
had sent in over the years that that
that by the time they offered it to me
I was ready and and and also it was
ready because it was Jo it was a creator
was hiring me so it wasn't some suit it
was one of us it was crater I really
admired it was one of my favorite
artists called me up and said your
artwork sucks
you're a writer let's get going right
and yeah I've told this story quite a
few times but it was a David Mac had
been hired before me at Marvel Knights
and Marvel Knights was really producing
some beautiful work and really was like
the cream of the crop in mainstream
comics at the time and and David was
writing daredevil and I was like Sean my
[ __ ] you know like you know when we all
do that you know show my stuff and and
he did and he finally got to a place to
joke we showed a couple my graphic
novels Joe called me right away and then
and then I I literally was like he goes
what would you do if you came to Marvel
like what were your passions and I said
well what do you need an artist for and
there was like literally dead silence on
the phone and he goes well if your
artworks not very good Brian
because you know your art work sucks she
was you know you're a very good writer
because I was assuming you were writing
you were drawing to show off your
writing and I was like no but I I know
feeling was that this is either gonna be
the greatest boss of all time right or
this is gonna go badly in a few months
and I was I was I've got him I've got
him mom you know to me like I got
someone's gonna hang my stuff on the
refrigerant Tommy
I need a boss will tell me the truth
tell me like that's what you need in
life you need people will constantly
tell you the truth so and also like once
you realize oh I'm now on the real stage
of comics like like and I remember like
when I got there double or spider-man
Joe had said welcome to comics and I
said I've been making comics for like
nine years he goes yeah welcome to
comics and I didn't know what he meant
and then when my first Marvel comics
came out of this is this is a way
different experience so there's like
actually people reading them so yeah it
was but but I love no but but like all
you know the people who read independent
comics love their comics and it's a deep
passion and it's tight and it was my
message board and and we're all buddies
and friends and maybe there's people
here from there that it's it's a real
great bond and then and then you get to
hear from the daredevil fans that's
that's a different that's a different
experience right and then and it was all
just building up to hear from the x-men
fans that's that's the the most hardcore
of hardcore oh right right yeah and it
was funny because even then I'd been I
just done like nine years on on Avengers
and I was taking over x-men and a couple
of x-men creators of past went get ready
I'm oh come on man I've been writing
Avengers like oh no no no every x-men is
someone's favorite that's a very unique
experience you know that like if you
that there's other you know that there's
a couple favorites but every x-men in
someone's favor you're gonna hear from
everybody so and I and I feel like I
climbed that like yeah you're right you
climbed that you climbed the ball they
can't be climbed it's a it's a and also
we recent it's on my mind I'm actually
last night was writing an x-men movie
for Fox which is very funny it's funny
no it's because I'm so immersed in DC
I'm so deeply deeply in my living in the
Daily Planet yeah that I that I that I
it's funny to be back in the x-mansion
well I'm not gonna ask for spoilers even
though I dearly want to but congrats
thank you there's a lot of gossip about
what it is online
so I mean I can keep going with the
transition because because it was a big
it honestly was a big deal that moved to
the mainstream comics I learned almost
everything I really learned about comics
I learned in that first year at Marvel
like the relationship with the audience
was a big one
I you know I I had such a snarky little
like Don Rickles attitude about
everything in you know my powers letter
column was just me goofing on everybody
and just having fun with it and it was
just making having fun everywhere and
then when you when you get to charitable
you you we're not joking around anymore
buddy this is Hell's Kitchen yeah so
yeah IIIi but I enjoyed it but that but
even like when I got there like there
would be people like reading spider-man
every week and screaming at me about it
I'm like well why do you buy it if you
don't like it like I don't understand
like I'm confused by that like there's I
I can't get through seven pages if I
don't like something I'm out in seven
pages I got I got kids I got life I got
you know I'm you know and and so I flat
out once I asked the question I said
what's the why are you buying this book
if and they said oh you know you like
comic Raiders I go yeah go well we're
we're like Marvel fans we're like
Yankees fans like they give you a sports
analogy you're gonna have to go look up
but because I don't know sports at all I
go but but we're like Yankees fans so
we're gonna scream the loudest if you
win and we're gonna boo the loudest if
you fail and that once that was opened
up to me I loved it I completely played
that game I honestly was one of the guys
I'm a message board said it to me and I
completely changed my stuff I was so
grateful and I and I've said it a few
times in interviews cuz I want whoever
that person was to tell them you
completely made my life easier well yeah
he was he was Marvel Knights was Joe and
Nancy and then literally I'd written
like two issues of daredevil and they
were written for like my best friend
David Mac and they asked us that like
come in and do daredevil because Kevin
Smith is very late and if you could just
hold
happens when you miss a deadline no but
also my career's filled with me being
there when someone else blew a deadline
I tell this to every creator because my
fortune has been made on other people
blow in their deadlines and and
daredevil was a gig that someone it was
someone else's job and they didn't hand
in their job to go they go here you guys
do a few issues and then we did our few
issues and then ago actually do a few
more he's gonna come back eventually and
so my first run I daredevil was my first
six issues was was I thought it was like
treading water for for for this big
comeback and then when he went and they
need wasn't coming back yeah yeah and
then and then I say yeah ultimate
spider-man was someone else's job there
was it was someone else had the job yeah
yeah so I and I don't say to be mean to
the other craters anything but it is a
when people ask what the magic trick is
show up also that's just awesome because
it's it's you were such a phenomenally
hard worker with so much passion but
it's opportunity meets you know the
skill the talent whatever and it's you
know and that's how luck happens well
the other the other thing is people
break in and they think that's it yeah
the easiest part is breaking it
it really is you think it's the hardest
part it's maintaining is-is-is because
it's not set up for the Creator to stay
it's it's actually set up for the crater
to be to be cycled out and so you have
to kind of make your own choices and a
lot of traders think that the publishers
making the choice for them and they're
not there's just it's not it's not it's
like you know you're looking at the
wrong thing you have to make the choices
yourself so and I was all very grateful
that like my like Joe and the people in
my life at Marvel and were very helpful
to me and also making that clear like
like you know I know it's very powerful
good thing and now it's not a bad thing
for some whose creators think that you
say no to a job oh they're never gonna
ask me for
no not it's not the case though they'll
take you much more seriously like oh you
you know your value yeah or or good
you're not gonna waste my time and write
something that you don't like editors
really admire and now they really do my
first edit it was John barber and he he
is the reason why I was able to maintain
a career at Marvel but also having been
a novelist and having seen how people
could be completely irrelevant after one
novel I also knew going in that the key
wasn't like you said it wasn't just that
you get a book it's about maintaining
your presence and continuing to write
and taking on projects and that was
that's a hard hard hard fought battle it
is it's it's it's shocking for some
people find out how much of life is like
a video game and that is if you always
get to do you think you're gonna hit the
boss level you know that was just the
door to the next thing you know yeah
it's yeah no matter what like and and
doing that while all the time centering
yourself and what you have to offer is a
creator what your what your truth is
what were what your goals are is is the
most important thing and and and for
those sitting here and I know there's
quite quite a few writers in here
looking for that for that for me to say
that and it's absolutely 100% true
you're gonna you're gonna be constantly
surrounded by people testing your
ability to stay true to yourself there's
gonna be constant constant ask for
compromise some of its gonna seem tiny
and some of its gonna seem enormous and
sometimes the enormous ones are going to
seem so enormous you have to think about
it for a while like why am I being asked
to make something red when I know it
should be blue sorry that's right and
and so and so your job is to create or
no matter what is it's just is to stay
true to yourself and by the way you can
do it being polite and and lovely you
know have to scream no no now in people
when you're when you're when you because
that that happens a lot but
but I do I do think that kindness and
passion you can get a lot done yeah oh
yes now also the great thing about
comics is that the wheels turn so fast
that if you just come at them with a
strong take again I know this is one of
the things that people think I'm in a
privileged position but you're talking
about my first years at marble I did not
have a published position but I become
at them with such a strong take on
spider-man that they went okay it's
either yes or no and this time it was
yes after nine years of it was a yes so
and and and the wheel has to turn so
quickly they don't have time to really
to second-guess you until next issue you
be keep going for a while I've used that
trick yeah it's not what it's it's one
that you don't do like evilly but you go
oh yeah if you want to slip in a couple
you know a couple moments in your story
they're a little bit more progressive
than what other people might want it's a
good opportunity to suppose you just do
it well since this actually segues
nicely because you've actually since you
know you started at Marvel gone on just
sort of shaped much of what we know
about the Marvel Universe it's hard for
me to see it that way okay well you know
for the rest of us I mean there was no
there was an enormous amount of people
in any room I was in yeah all always so
it's always I always felt to me like I
had a front-row seat to it more than I
more than more than what the way you
wording and I didn't outstanding seach
one of the great pop culture stories of
our generation I was there when they
were in bankruptcy like when I my first
visit to Marvel they were selling they
were selling five and cabinets for cash
there was actually a post-it note on a
pile of filing cabinets that said sold
on them and the lights were off in the
bullpen and you've given visited how
they limited toilet paper yeah in the
bathroom was because it cost too much
yeah so I was there for that and then I
was there for this show it was so it's
been quite a quite oh I do where there
was genuine times where I thought Oh am
i writing the last Marvel comic what
honor I literally said well if I'm
reading the last Marvel comic really
really bring it home cuz okay it really
felt that way you're like oh everyone
they hired me because everyone else left
it's it's really stuff a lot of people
went off to video games and being Dave
over there going all this we got to do
it once yeah yeah it did but I was I
would but the other version was that in
in bankruptcy in complete devastation
comes hey let's roll up our sleeves and
go nuts lets everyone just everyone just
tell crazy stories and there's like
listen for closing the doors we might as
well go out swinging and so there was
that kind of feeling to and the boss
who's running it was determined not to
let the doors close so he was making
deals with payless shoes and getting
awesome spider-man and every shoe box in
the country and so there was a lot of
genuine movement to get the to get the
ships running but the with hiring me and
Mark Miller and a few other people was
definitely like hey let's let them do
what everybody
nothing else is working and and and and
and that with that comes genuine
enthusiasm like if everyone's we're kind
of creating for the right reason you
know well Jim Lee calls you an impact
player make a lot of changes good
changes and I was just you know I'm not
gonna ask you for like long term
spoilers as far as the DC Universe goes
but what has been one of the great joys
and difficulties and then transition to
DC well first of all and we're talking
about fear earlier this this the move to
DC terrify me I was it was it was deeply
scary and and there's quite a few things
I've done this year that I've been as
scared creatively as I've ever been and
and I'm so if I'm a deeply proud of
myself for putting myself in this
situation yet again where I could've not
I could have picked things that I could
have relaxed a little bit but this this
this whole year has been just just just
a
holding on to the railing you know thing
but the the the plus for me was and the
the choice was made before I got sick
was getting to write Superman all year
after everything that we me and Lisa had
been through and and the trans and
everything that's going on in the world
and trying to raise my multiracial
family in this increasingly stressful
nightmare that world that we're growing
in having to spend hours a day trying to
think what would the best person do like
all he can do was the best thing what's
the best thing and in it and it makes me
feel of this on David Mamet line from
the movie heist that that I that I used
to quote all the time but now I'm kind
of living it it's a gene Hackman is his
thief and they go how did you come up
with this great plan he goes I thought
of a smarter person and I thought what
would they do and I and I and I
literally that's how I think when I'm
writing sprite a Superman I did it
Superman
is as I think he he's better than me
what would he do right and so you have
to spend hours a day be its thinking
what the best thing you could do is and
then when you're when you're out in the
real world you can't then go fight with
people the grocery store you're you're
thinking about you're thinking like like
Superman I'm being much more helpful and
being much more can I help you with that
ma'am I'm doing that a lot more than I
used to do and and I find my my my
parenting Zen my Conda come you have to
have when when faced with you know and I
for kids so we can really get a circus
going it's much more more potent to my a
my I do everything with the hands on the
hips but i but i but so I'm insanely
grateful for Superman being in my life
right now at this age and I and I think
a lot about how much of Peter Parker is
inside me and and how much of that
nervous energy that
I poured in on my pages that I lived
with and now as a more mature man iiiii
I have a more centered energy and now
I'm more tapped into that so I find that
fascinating and Myles is quite in the
middle there so I'm always I've always
kind of journey with with my energy
without without being conscious of it so
I'm grateful for that that's the hardest
thing is DC continuity Marvel
well Marvel never rebooted for all of
its mishegoss Marvel is a straight line
right it's a straight line you know but
it yeah but but but but there have been
start starting stops so you could be
reading a graphic novel and then find
Ono this doesn't this doesn't count
right so so that that is the biggest but
but honestly there was like a DC
Universe year by your visual book that
helped me put it all together it was so
great one of those big giant DK books
you know it helped me just lined it all
up in and and make some choices for
myself that was really really great so
yeah of all the things this really
helped me yeah because I'd read almost
all of it and also how interesting it is
to have read so much stuff as a fan
never giving it any like potent brain
power like what would I do with Batman
like I never actually went there because
I've so much of that part of my brain is
in use right now is I never was like
fantasizing about what you know Legion
of super-heroes would be like I never
thought of it but now like so rereading
this material as someone who could
actually help author this is really
unique oh it's so exciting it's deeply
exciting and also just to look at some
of the choices other creators have made
that I may not have understood at the
time but now I can understand them like
as a creator with a little bit more
under my belt okay yeah yeah so both
things and also I must say I love
there's something genuinely awesome
about living in the DC Universe right
now because it is not our world it's a
different you know I mean it's there's
difference it's a it's Marvel is our
world's New York City in Chicago in LA
DC is metropolis Gotham there's there's
a there's a disconnect then now lets us
get to more truth you know now we're now
we're in a fantasy world like you like a
monstrous so now I can really talk about
some stuff because we're not I'm not
pointing any fingers I'm just talking
about real stuff yeah that I love okay
well I want to take some questions
sigh whoa so that we can include you in
the videos we do need people who want to
ask questions to please go to these mics
that are in the hallway or in the
walkways here the stairways and I will
say that if you have specific questions
about your writing that you said I don't
want to ask that in the microphone do it
because you'll be surprised how many
people are feeling the same feeling or
expressing the same are having the same
frustrations so or we could just go here
we go I think you're the ending the
death that you gave Peter Parker in your
run for ultimate spider-man is honestly
think it's one of the most beautiful
Comics comic moments I've ever seen
thank you how did you feel when another
writer decided to just drag the dead
horse back oh no no I I draw I dragged
that horse out III wanted that I wanted
that horse back out what uh what
motivated you to do that um I knew I was
leaving and I wanted to put the toy back
for other writers who have why should
they be denied what I was given which is
that playground that I loved and I and I
I often think what I would want if I
would like if I was the other creator
and I'll just do that because you here
see we've both heard these horrific
stories of creators - screwing over
other creators like with story lines or
just editorial decisions that they knew
was going to mess them up and I would I
I would like to go through life never
having anyone ever said that about me it
was just interesting since like your run
with Miles Morales was great and I
thought you'd beautifully just set him
up is like you know the mainstay in the
ultimate universe since it was removed
but regardless let's thank you no you
know I just thought we got to a place
where we could have both and I think the
movie proves me right so yeah over here
I really have proof that I was
about anything so I got to via powers so
that was my first I hadn't really
actually read the Marvel bits but on
hope a are you gonna do any more powers
Bureau and secondly could you discuss a
little bit since you were I didn't
realize you were an artist I'm not that
familiar with your background your
cooperation as a writer with your
artists yeah you just talk about that
III two things number one yes yes the
good news great I have powers good news
which is that the 20th anniversary
because we're old people is is is this
summer and so a DC Comics will be
releasing a brand new powers graphic
novel that's already written and drawn
and we're actually adding a lot more
onto it because we realize it was a 20th
anniversary we're gonna make it a very
special celebration we're not putting it
out as the miniseries but as a graphic
novel so no one has to wait they can
just have it because we're we're sorry
for the wait so yes
two more powers and it's it's pretty
it's pretty big it's like a hundred
eighty pages long so it's it's a there's
a lot of not to show you there and the
powers is actually a great example of
why I'm not drawing because literally
when I first met my combing and at a
signing in Philadelphia you mean David
Mac and Mike I mean we just didn't
really know each other we're coming buds
on the road and Mike was developing his
what would become his power style and he
went home and he sent over drawings of
my character Jenks and David Mack's
character kabuki in that style that he
was drawing and I immediately would have
rather that book be in Mike style than
my style like Amelie was like like
personally as a fan I would rather than
what I'm doing and I I called up David
and I said are we gonna fight over him
or can I just have them because because
clearly we need to work with him and so
I I and Mike and I were not friends we
did not know each other and I just
called him up and I said I had this idea
it's you know homicide book
and he literally that night sent in the
first drawings of Christian Walker and
Mike was over my house two nights ago
and I can tell you that he's like my
brother like so I went from like like it
throughout the creation of powers and
everything we've been through and the TV
show and all that having just created my
family around that it's quite something
so thank you yeah
Marjorie do you want to mention your
relationship with your artist with
monstrous yeah because it was the first
question I asked you when I saw you
today was was about how you guys work
together you know I actually met Sanne
when we were working on x-23 she was the
fill-in artist initially and then I
loved her work so much it was so
evocative that I requested her when our
actual artist you know went off to do
other things I think he was pulled you
know for an Avengers event or something
and so is this me you're talking about
okay so I worked out for me you know in
a great opportunity because we just
totally I mean I fell in love with her
style she was absolutely amazing but and
what's happened since then is that you
know we're doing monstrous and you know
alright she lives in Japan when we first
started out she didn't speak any English
she had a trans and she had an a
translator and so she would get the
scripts in English they would be
translate into Japanese and then she was
draw them and she would draw her x-23
books in like two weeks like I swear to
god this woman was like a beast she
would just whip them out and and
monstrous now takes her about six to
seven weeks per issue but the detail and
what she pours into this book you know
that our collaborative process for me is
is like having a psychic bond with
someone because even well before we
started writing the first issue I would
give her notes and the barest barest
notes and she would come back with these
character designs that were as if she
had reached into my head and pulled out
my dreams it was actually incredibly
profound and so whenever I get pages
from her it is
like I'm seeing someone just manifests
my imagination on the page it's one of
the most beautiful things I've
experienced and I've worked with a ton
of amazing artists vasana
whatever we've got going on I have no
words for it but it's special and
sometimes in this business that's what
makes it really beautiful when you
collaborate with an artist and you you
just you click something happens and no
matter the rest of the world could hate
your work and be like this is the worst
thing we've ever read but between you
and this other creator it's magic and
and for me that's one of the reasons why
I write comics because I love the medium
but also because I love the
collaborative process and I love that
magic eye and I was telling you
sonna really upsets a lot of other
artists so it's so intricate because
there's really two things she does that
are antithetical to like what most
comics are which is she designed
costumes that are so elaborate that she
now has to draw in every panel that
elaborate because now that book is about
elaborate design right so and I made me
laugh because I thought like Joe and
Sarah Pacelli were designing Miles
Morales costume and they did the reverse
web line which is so hard to draw ask
anybody it's it's literally the opposite
of easy and and and so and Joe came up
with it and then left and then like and
like all these artists and I start
drawing the the hardest costume right
and and and and she's doing it with glee
like are in monsters but you definitely
have that thing once you're like working
with someone doesn't even speak the same
language as you but it's working and you
know what's working on this other level
you like you want you just want to run
it and scream to everybody it shouldn't
be working it's it's it's the best
feeling in the world I first of all
thank you
there's been so much of your work that's
meant so much to me so thank you I
appreciate it
secondly as far as the question you
mentioned there being so much of Peter
Parker in you and I assume that's kind
of a two-way street
isn't everything though oh yeah I like
as a writer that's what you have to do
but how like I'm working on a project
right now that's one of those things
where like the fears the fear makes it
really easy to want to stop and I don't
think I can but it's so much of me that
it's hard to get that out especially
like a character who's a different
generation for example you may have
heard people talk about this online it's
very hard to talk about but what you you
what you need to do is to get into
almost a Zen state when you're when
you're writing which is I'm not saying
like all to yourself but stop thinking
about all the stuff you're thinking
about just don't think about anything
about what this character needs to do
right now like right this second what
does this character need to do right and
if you have trouble even getting there
you can start with the easiest thing you
can do in genre which is take your
character and put them into place they
least want to be all right whatever that
is and let's say you're writing about
you where it was the place that you
least wanted to be at the moment and
then put yourself there and then write
yourself out of it
all right and just do that and by doing
that you've now created almost like a
survivor story when you're not even
thinking about anything but how can I
get out of this situation and then
you're gonna read back what you wrote
and go all I wrote all that stuff I was
worried about it's all in there all
right all that stuff happens but only
when you literally stop thinking about
it it's literally like if you stop
thinking about being single like you
didn't mean like if you're like it's the
same thing like well the minute you stop
thinking about it you meet the perfect
person right it's it's the same thing
just stop thinking about it and you and
you will get there does that make sense
yeah and I know it's one of those things
that's easier to do than say but but I
I've talked to a lot of craters about it
and it really is you just got it you got
it you got to just get there I'm done
I'm done worrying about it just gonna do
it and then and then on sometimes it's
always a matter of just looking at one
other creator going oh they did it and
they're stupid I'm going to do
yeah so and I know that I'm bad for a
lot of people there are people who read
my scripts ago he can't even spell and
he got in so yeah get in sorry mr.
Bendis I've been a big fan for a long
long time I kind of got like a two-part
question I was wondering what you
thought about of the heroes in crisis
like story and you know how we writers
decided the faith like anybody could be
anybody who would win a fight between
Captain Marvel and Superman if you were
to write that ha ha ha ha
who would win if I beaten Captain Marvel
Superman yes so stupid but to ask your
thank you what asks your it's your
earlier question I do love here was in
crisis I'll tell you why what tom is
bringing is real truth he has lived a
life and has feelings and has no problem
putting them on the page and and it's
doing so almost in like a punk rock kind
of like way that I think is very very
good for comics and it's exactly what
I'm speaking of and and I can point to
see that that's what I'm talking about
is his truth and and and for me who
never had PTSD in my life of until this
year I'm actually genuinely grateful for
him like I got to read the first three
issues of heroes before anyone else did
and I was like I generally don't know
but this is just what I needed
right now or this is your this is the
best thing you've ever done because this
hit me it punched me right in the chest
yeah and I got the next issue I can't
even tell you how many comics have made
me feel that way you can count them on a
hand like deeply like hit me right so I
was I was grateful for it so yeah thank
you sir thank you it's good to meet you
thank you hey just want to say thanks to
both of you for participating this has
been great um when you said earlier you
know learning how to say no to our
project that seems really odd to me just
cause in my day job you're taught you
never say no to a project right you
always say yes you take all more work
you put more on your plate when do you
know when to say no well it's different
for freelancers there's there's
different I I've never had a real job
but I know people
who have and they've told me about it so
I know that there's there's a different
there's different ways to success in
different things but for freelancers
you're every time you take a job it
could be a Scrooge McDuck you're giving
your you're giving of yourself
you're putting yourself you're putting
your name on something and you're and
you're putting yourself out there it is
it is a piece of you and you really
should take that under consideration and
you know what me I'm not taking away
from the like you know what I need to
pay my rent and I've done I've did a
Star Trek gig to pay my rent and then in
and but.okay
find my truth in there absolutely you
can you absolutely take a gig but but
then fine fine to find you find yourself
fine find a reason that makes it special
that you did it so my name is also
Marjorie oh yeah no I am I've had I've
gone through certain situations in my
life as a writer where I have been asked
to do certain things like one of the
first question one of the first big
questions I was ever asked that I had to
say no - was that an editor wanted me to
mind me to change my name because it was
thought that a Chinese name wouldn't
sell books what yeah and I said no to
that
and so you get questions like if you're
you know if you're a person of color
sometimes you get questions like that I
have been you know I was asked to make a
character white because they didn't like
the fact that the hero was brown and
that they didn't want to have to put a
brown person on the cover of the book
mm-hmm
and I had to say no to that now that's
just what novels
I mean comics are entirely safe but it
was it was a little they're not looked
at problems yeah they're not entirely on
the hook I was sitting I couldn't even
think of who you were talking about this
was when I started my career as a
novelist you know when it came to when
it came to Marvel for example I was
actually pretty lucky at marble to work
with fantastic people but towards the
end of my time at Marvel not including
Han Solo I got to the point where I was
just itching to do something else you
know when you write corporate comics at
a certain point sometimes you know
you're writing for a corporation you
don't own the characters and that's
something that's easy to forget you know
because I became so invested in
characters like x-23 and the x-men and
all that and then all of a sudden you're
like it doesn't matter how much you
remind yourself and they're not yours
at a certain point you know you you
forget in order to invest yourself and
my and my the way the universe keeps
reminding me is crazy
the miles is on the cover is on the can
of Campbell's soup this week there's
Campbell's soup cans it's crazy ya know
I I didn't know that was a goal of mine
until I saw it okay I'm so proud of
myself I and so I got offered you know
towards the end I got offered two books
and I would have under certain
circumstances I would have loved doing
them but I realized the corporate
controls were going to be such that I
couldn't tell the story I want to tell I
couldn't and I I decided that it was
time for me to do independent comics I
had to leave it didn't I didn't have a
project I didn't have monsterous at that
point I didn't have anything to to
cushion the fall I just knew I couldn't
do this anymore I had to write my own
thing and so I said no I said no to big
books that you know otherwise might have
been great to do but I was done so what
happens yeah by the way you could hear
these stories going back to the terry
gilliam story is that they they wanted
him to do the hottest script in
Hollywood was enemy mine and he said no
I got a better script it's Brazil they
go better than any mine and
they made his movie that's that's I know
is very very sexy I have two questions
one short and one long the first the
short one is you said three words that
really hit my heart which is a legion of
super-heroes so is there anything you
can say about them they're cool yeah you
know because Legion fans want them to
come back they're worse than x-men all I
could say is that if someone was
preparing a run on Legion supers it is
easily the hardest job to prepare
reference and research for that that
they could ever imagine but I just
that's all I heard that I don't know if
that's true yeah and then a second you
know I grew up in a time where it was
letter columns that you learned how
people felt about a book and that was
five months after the issue came out and
now you've got Twitter where people will
give full reviews in 140 characters and
so my question to you really both of you
is how do you interact with fans that
way do you read blogs do you check
tweets do you shut them all out do you
go to places like CBR or bleeding cool
and read what they have to say do you go
to message boards like I mean do you
immerse yourself in what fans have to
say or do you distance yourself or is it
a mix I'd like to hear your answer in
this I am NOT you know ever since the
2016 election I've been pulling myself
off Twitter because it just became too
stressful and I realized that I could be
an advocate and an activist in ways that
didn't involve 140 characters but that
involved actual real-life feet on the
ground work also including the work I
was doing the writing and so but but
even before that I didn't read reviews I
never read reviews as a novelist didn't
go to Amazon and scour you know I didn't
do it because and occasionally you know
you can't always escape reviews and if
they were negative
I read the negative reviews and I was
grateful for them because I inevitably
learned something criticism is good you
know you can learn a lot and sometimes
it's valid sometimes it's not be take
what you think is useful and you
incorporate that you know because as a
writer I am always learning there has
never been a point in my life where I
thought damn I got this because I don't
we know a couple of people who genuinely
feel that way once in a while like my
god like Mark Miller he says it online
all the time so it's not like we're
gossiping because I've never felt that I
never felt that never and he genuinely
feels it and sometimes he's right he
nailed it but I've never ever felt that
much and so and so and and also you know
I think that for me I I love my readers
and I for them and I I have really great
interactions with my readers for the
most part you know and thankfully but
you know I I will when I was on Twitter
mostly I would I would engage every now
and then but for me to meet a reader in
real life and engage like that's why I
do Comic Cons because I like seeing
people face-to-face and talking with
them and actually you know having a
conversation and I grew up before social
media I didn't have the internet until I
was 18 I grew up having conversations
with people and I hate to sound so old
but I missed that I missed that and
that's that's kind of what feeds me yeah
and I was lucky like I came up while
like the the social media of comics was
building itself like I had a message I
was one of the first message boards and
and and when I was Indian and and so I
kind of like grew up with as it evolved
so I I was able to like gently make the
mistakes you would make which is oh
they're over there talking about
ultimate spider-man I'll chime in
oh they actually did not want me to
chime in well you know that you like
you're like oh we're all friends will
come and I can I can help with this
conversation no no that was their
conversation and your room dit value of
I by showing up over there so I you
learn you learn you learn that and yeah
you learnt just to stay in your lane and
if people need you they come find out
there's no reason the venture forth it's
it's yeah everyone has their own space
you don't need but but what I what I
feel deeply honored by to be honest and
and this is because I
to work with so many of my heroes is
that they'll tell you like Bill sing
Kevin's will tell you when he was on New
Mutants they got two letters he had no
idea he was blowing our minds no idea he
was sitting in his room going mom taking
some big shots here huh yeah hopefully
everyone likes it and and had no idea
that he was like altering us like it
literally changed in our lives so I'm
genuinely grateful that like every
Wednesday and it does feel like like and
instead of in sports every and every
given Sunday you're the hero the villain
of the game for comics is every given
Wednesday its it every any Wednesday and
I'm I've done what I've done right or oh
you you know it's it's it's and it's and
and most of the time I generally no idea
what it is that's gonna set people off
good or bad and that's a great that's an
exciting feeling it is I do I genuinely
love the adventure and as far as
critique goes I have found that most of
it is is very truthful and honest and
that you can and and the ones that
aren't you can tell right away like when
you see a review we're talking about if
they wrote the book I'm like okay that's
you're coming from a different place
right but when when you read a review
and it's and it's painful you go that's
true that that you then you know that's
true with that if that really hurt your
feelings then that this is this is true
and if and I've read like a rave review
of something where I said well that's
not true either that it is not it's got
some problems I know what the problems
are I will do better next time
right but so I've had the experience
both not having my mind changed with
someone hated something and I loved and
like it's usually the baby and the one
that everyone is happen I know that's
the one you you hug the most right and
and and other things that people have
been very generous to me about I I
dasn't made me love it any more if that
makes sense and and but instead of just
focusing on that I apply it to the next
thing like okay well then how I'm
feeling now I should apply to this issue
of Superman and make it more honest and
more true and and you know and do all
those things so I so I think it's but
but
just spending all day online reading
about yourself it could not be more of a
trap
like like holy Lord that is not what
yeah you're not supposed to be doing
that you're supposed to be researching
your work and and helping other other
creators with their work that's what you
should be doing online and I'm sitting
there obsessively reading about what
people think about the thursdays and
jessica jones or something i that's it's
it's good I know it's yeah II go surfing
and I think I read I read a quote by
Maya Rudolph of all people in in
interview magazine and she said that she
realized that a lot of people center
live were sitting around reading every
review every tweet everything and then
they would only be satisfied when they
read the worst thing they could possibly
read about themselves like you could
skip over a hundred good comments about
why that was funny Bible but when
someone says something so brutal you go
woof like Anderson and she realized it
was something like I love as like a
version of like cutting like you're
literally trying to hurt yourself you're
literally looking for a way to make
yourself feel bad so you can feel good
and and once you realize that stop
that's you've got to stop them
immediately so that's uh yeah so it's
been many many years since I've ever
thanks for much I can help with the
Legion if you need it so what was that
I'm sorry I didn't hear what are you
saying thank you which one's chameleon
boy I'm sorry I Brian I've been a fan
since the Espiral issue of torso so a
long long time good to see you healthy
thank you
I know chickens begin to influence I
know ma'am it's a big influence I also
know you're a huge Howard Stern fan and
I want to know what your experience is
there you know growing up with that and
has that influenced you I know you've
had some run-ins with him I want to hear
about that kind of I did I haven't
listened in a few years it was the
fourth child was the one that night that
was it no choices had to be made and I'm
but bummed out because the show has
evolved in into the the interviews
lately the Neil Young I do hear the big
interviews you did an hour and a half a
Neil Young that was just riveting just
about process it
it's it's become a process junkie show
and of all the things you think that Joe
would had turned into that's kind of
amazing but yeah years ago I got a call
from Joe Quesada he said come to come to
New York this week we have a meeting
with Howard Stern and I was like what
and I was like as in you can get an e
goes and we we we were literally in
Howard Stern's apartment talking about
making a superhero franchise for him but
like it was weird it was a weird day and
I loved every second of it and it was
actually a day he actually took himself
off the air to show that the FCC what
it'll be like if FCC goes after him and
then and then and so we were there where
he was lost out of Canada to win is like
penthouse apartment in Central Park West
overlooking the universe and the tallest
man in the world met this little Jewish
man and and yeah it was like meeting I
felt like Frodo yeah and and and and we
sat and talked about comic books and
making a superhero out of Howard Stern
and I knew it was never gonna happen in
a million years I knew this was the
meaning he was taking as the serious
deal was being put together and I didn't
mind it at all usually I you you get
into meetings like that you like oh this
is not a real meeting you've got those
right yeah and and so but that one I was
like I'm completely entertained I'm
getting my own private Howard Stern Show
it was it went out for like nine hours
it's great it's cool yeah it was the
best yeah I just want to say thank you
have been a fan since since way back and
ultimate spider-man was incredible and
Superman is my all-time favorite so when
you made the announcement you're moving
over I was as thrilled as could be
are there any characters like Cannell
that that you knew out the gate you
wanted to play with when you move to DC
like you know are there any things that
you're like if I could ever
if I get angle things that I could play
with that guy I would love to yeah
you're genuinely seeing them like like
this is this is it you're like wonder
comics is a perfect representation of
what III thought at least and I could
bring to DC though that they weren't
doing that wasn't
and when the idea of the pop-up ream
print was was floated by me it was it
was an empty bowl like I could fill it
with anything and and I was like oh and
and my first instinct was oh I'll make a
bunch of crime comics and then I realize
oh jinkx well there's a bunch I'm
actually doing a handful of crime comics
right now and and but but boy these all
these characters that I love aren't in
any book at all and and so so Young
Justice and and I said like like an
ultimate line but like it with a
different purpose but but with a
different but with a similar kind of
these characters are at that moment
where they're discovering themselves and
and that's you know a great thing that
comics has and and so Young Justice and
Wonder Twins and die Elise for hero but
it's also having dollies for hero by
saying Humphries like I I'm very
selfishly making a comic book that I
would like to have a copy of like that
literally is I've never felt so selfish
and and Wonder Twins
mabye Wonder Twins and I literally was
like well I would I wouldn't just by
anyone who twins I one day I would want
DC to show me someone who might go oh I
have to buy that and Mark Russell who
just did Flintstones and it's absolutely
that guy so we're we're making comics
that I desperately would buy yeah that's
what the characters to all of them will
be showing up thank you very much thank
you thank you so has it been weird
watching Scarlett come true yes it is
because IIIi do a book called Scarlett
tech takes place in Portland and things
keep happening in Portland at the same
locations that happened in the book that
we did photo reference out and that was
very strange yeah it's it's very weird
and I was going to ask you about this
about monsters as well because it
monstrous reflects it was born in a
different world right monstrous was born
born years ago and if a world and now
it's existing in this world well it was
before 2016 no like Scarlett was born
in the Obama years and now it's
reflected of a completely different
society that that I but reflects its
truth differently than I planned but
gets there faster and and I I'm amazed
by I've never had that feeling before
I've never had a narrative alter itself
because of the real world and not alters
of it but it reflects it differently to
the the audience sees it differently
well let's wonder it's weird because
sometimes as a writer you know in my
life I've wondered sometimes if
unconsciously you know not just me but
I've talked with other writers who feel
the same way that if unconsciously in
the moment of creation we are not like
picking up on something because so often
the work that we do years later or maybe
not so many years later it it is in the
right it is it is in the right moment
you know it's as if we could tell the
future where we could pick up on a
thread of the future and we were writing
something that there was going to be a
need for for that would you know raise
questions that were appropriate for the
time that we found ourselves in and it's
a very strange sensation when that
happens the new police police
commissioner in a police captain in
Portland her last name is justice and
I'm like oh I would never name my
character
[Laughter]
thank you guys for being here my
question is really centered around
endings because we live in this culture
of you know what's next you know that
there's no cohesive ending for something
and as a you know writer and artist
myself I struggle with crafting the
ending that feels satisfying
while trying to balance the urge to keep
pushing forward and to like make that
next thing because I'm genuinely excited
so I'm just wondering if you had advice
you know it's something I wrestle with
all the time it's one of those things
there's no right or wrong answer for in
every project in character offers their
own solutions right and first I I come
from the Stan Lee school which is every
comic is someone's first and last and
it's your fault either way and and that
is that so that clipping or you know
Stan never ended a story it never and
never fully ended it was always like
even if it was a big win and a half
be ending oh but then there was
something else right so there's an
always another reason to pick up the
next issue so I'm a big big believer in
that and also it's a reflection of life
it never just if there's always
something else you're always like you
you solve that problem up there's a new
problem so so I I I focus on making the
moments as true as possible so the
ending then becomes inevitable right
it's the only ending the story could
possibly have and we couldn't have
possibly ever saw it coming
that's that's the goal for a great
ending of a story right isn't how I said
that it's it's the like when people see
it they go that's the only ending it
could have ever had I'm just gonna add
on just really quick that there's
something about a beautiful ending and I
think because I come from Ryan fanfic
many many many many years ago that
allows for also in addition to that
possibilities you allow the reader
possibilities continue dreaming of these
characters and I think that's something
else that a great ending does a loss in
translation the movie that that's that's
the perfect ending to that movie all
right the the they go their separate
ways with a secret that's none of our
business
all right so that that song it can be as
elegant as that and and I think that's
what I think about often that it doesn't
have to be the dust star explodes it can
be I love you and I like quitting and I
couldn't say those words until now
that's a great ending to a story thank
you right hey Brian I just want to say
thank you for creating co-creating Myles
because uh it's um I relate a lot to
spider-man and it's like cool to see a
character I mean obviously it's a bunch
of characters it's like that like look
like me you know like rocket like that
yeah so it's it's just cool for that
especially you know when the movies
gonna come out I'm gonna take my little
cousin so that's gonna be cool
it's good
[Laughter]
with making it so I can say this without
any ego and I could say it with I was
holding my breath girl please I kind of
met the guy that made him but anyway so
two things second one's kind of long but
the first thing is I'm a big fan of
legacy legacy characters and I wanted to
know if maybe you were gonna in the
future introduce like the JSA into like
Superman or action comics like not not
so much for Superman before Jonathan you
know cuz it's just kind of like yeah
John if anything we're also obviously a
huge fan of legacy characters as well
and DC DC it's a completely unique
animal in that area so there's so many
characters that are legacy characters
that are sometimes abandoned unity mean
so you like like even like the Young
Justice like all those characters are
being written right now so I wanna I
want to you know get get going for their
what's coming with John is a very very
special unique storyline that's gonna
take up this whole run of Superman he's
coming back next issue and he's coming
back with an entirely huge story that
happened with him and his grandfather
and his mother out in space and and and
and we're gonna we're gonna show you
some stuff about John the Superman
family we've never seen before which I'm
excited about it and it's all a
reflection getting back to truth a
reflection of you know having all my
children and all of them having a very
unique perspectives and unique abilities
and unique needs and and and
and reflecting that on to Superman and
his son is a lot of it's very joyful
thing for me so the second thing I
wanted to ask is the includes about your
family also because um as a creator of
characters that are people of color is
it I want to know about like the kind of
the process cuz I know you said you have
a multiracial family someone know like
how that especially like as a white male
like it's how how does that work exactly
like the process its number one it's not
sometimes it's never as complicated as
boy I am very aware of what my kids are
like taking in in this culture and and
and the voices and the characters that
they see and for kids of color it though
it is much better than it used to be it
is still there's only like a couple of
flavors that they see on a daily basis
you know the you know the the brown skin
Kate is usually the sassy best friend
you know other than Casey and recover
and a couple others but through but you
go yeah there's more flavors out there
there's more experience and perspective
out there that it's not being reflected
to these children and so they walk
through life with with a culture that
doesn't reflect truth to them or they
have to dig deep to find something to
connect to and and when you're aware of
that and you're in a position to change
any of it or to be additive in any way
shape or form but you've got to take
every opportunity to do so so that's
where we came from and and you know and
miles came from like an earlier version
of that thought process and and and now
we're adding characters into action
comics in DC and we have a new book
called Naomi David Walker Knight coming
out that's a very substantial additive
element to the DC Universe not just with
what the character and and her point of
view but she's going to be bringing
things to the DC Universe that were not
there before so it just seems to me that
there's tons of story not being told and
I can get there a little bit from my
perspective and and then
I hopefully that helps everybody else
get get there as well but but yeah I
just I just I I see what's missing and I
can't do all of it but I can do so I can
do some of it all so I'm not the voice
that should do all of it I there's
clearly hundreds of people more
qualified to do this but I'll do my part
thank you first of all thank you both
second so you both have the unique and
really cool experience of writing
characters that have blockbuster
legacies behind them so I was really
curious to hear a story of when you felt
like balancing that legacy or that maybe
corporate dynami of character conflicted
it with your view of that character in
the how like what was the process of
either saying no and and how it was
resolved or what was the experience like
well while you think III well III just
my mind I don't think about with the
corporate thinks about the character I
think about what's like the world thinks
about the character it is a shared
character Superman it's a shared
character that is that is Superman is
everybody spider-man is everybody's not
every characters like that but Superman
Batman
you know Wonder Woman these are these
are shared characters and when you feel
like like the Wonder Woman will be being
a perfect example of that's how we all
feel about her that's it you did it like
that that's not a corporate thing that's
a that's a that's a cultural thing so I
think more about that than I do about
what you know yeah I mean I would say
you know basically I have like a similar
approach so when I was writing the x-men
when I was writing x-23 Black Widow I
was really trying to put myself in the
skin of these characters and really
think about you know what their pain is
what their joy is what drives them and
and just inhabit them and I I didn't I
never really came up against anything as
far as early on especially when it was
only much later in my career that I
started you know butting heads a little
bit with the way certain characters be
portrayed and those are on books I
ultimately said no
- the only time I ever had laugh was
when I was writing han Solo
and and I had him drawing his blaster
first I was shocked I was like it's such
a small thing and they're like no no so
I won't go into the full details of that
exchange but that's but other other than
those books I actually ultimately said
no - that was the only time I really sat
back and I was like wow this is this is
this is this is real but I do love
discovering that there was an argument
among fans about our character that I
was unaware and and that could still
happen and I'm so online that I'm always
surprised that there's some deep thing
going on that I that I missed out on but
yeah I've enjoyed my my new DC I I'm the
voice breaking up the fight between the
super boys the first round of hate mail
I ever got when I was at Marvel was
because it was during my my run of x-23
and it was because one of the teenage
characters makes a comment about psy
locks cellulite in a snarky teen way I
got so much [ __ ] for that so much [ __ ]
all of the fanboys came out which is
like no she does not have cellulite that
is terrible how could you say that and I
was like all right Wow okay to give you
each about two minutes each because I
would like to respect the fact you've
been waiting for a while and oh yeah
absolutely
okay yeah this is a in regards to miles
and riri Williams and I guess my
question was um you know we talked about
social media and people's opinions
online and there's obviously a
contingent of folks online who are comic
book fans who do not like the
representation that is out there and I'm
just curious when you first started you
know in choosing the characters was
there any pushback from the company or
from the creators and if there was how
did you handle that and I guess my other
question I don't want to ask super our
question is that
being that you know you're writing about
characters of color I know you talked
about your kids and you want the
reputation for your kids how did you as
a white male you know go about with the
process of writing for characters of
color did you was there was there a need
or a process of having a conversation
with folks about kind of their
perspective and what does some important
issues that need to be tackled with
these characters you asked all the
excellent questions that I wanted to
talk about earlier so thank you bright
this is good I number one nobody
corporate I've never never got any
pushback on anything in fact Miles was
created in such a beautiful vacuum of
what if why don't we and and on a book
that was successful and did it neat it
wasn't being done out of stress or our
need or you know which is sometimes how
things are done at a out of panic and
fear it was being done out of why don't
we what's stopping us we should write
and and and once the stories truth which
was the death of Peter Parker revealed
itself that then we're like alright
that's we're doing it that's let's do it
and I was so grateful that the response
two miles matched what was going on
behind the scenes because audience would
it know what's going on behind the
scenes all they know is they were going
to react to what they're seeing right
and what they saw reflected well it
doesn't always happen that way but this
this one did and I was it was an
enormous thing in my life it's hard to
describe because I was at the center of
a lot of people coming up to me of
different backgrounds and ethnicities
going seriously don't mess this up
seriously seriously like I am and like
and a friend of mine I was I was on the
I was working on the powers TV show and
I'll say who was was Carrie Payton was
actually the voice of cyborg came up to
me and told me and this is before anyone
knew anything he just heard I was doing
spider-man and that there was a
brown-skinned involved right and he
pulled me aside on setting because I'm
gonna tell your story and he told me
that when I was a kid all our friends
played superheroes and my friends
wouldn't let me be Batman or Superman
because I'm a color my skin but I could
be spider-man
and that's why you know like spider-man
can't be anybody kids of color think
that like so you should know that and I
didn't know that but what was amazing
was he told me the story
I then realized it was maybe the 80th
person who had told me a version of the
story throughout the years I was writing
spider-man but I was just hearing it as
they this is why spider-man relates to
everybody right I wasn't hearing no you
need to do more well I I and and and
once I was there I realized oh this is
what I was being told for years so so it
felt like the right Road the entire time
and that felt good so that felt good and
so here we are at the at the you know
weeks away from the movie debut in Yuen
Li the relief I have is enormous because
it's always smiles and everything like
that's always been treated it's been
done the right way as far as how we want
to go about this this is something I
actually wanted to bring up in this
classroom environment there is you know
with everyone kind of learning how to
write their truth and right from their
experience there's also kind of a weird
thing going on where where there's a
being taught like no you should only
write what you know and don't write
other people's perspective you should
only write your thing and I'm not sure
exactly where that's coming from that's
not how literature is made that's not
how stories are told a part of our job
as writers is to go out into the world
and and investigate and embrace and and
understand and find the empathy and find
the understanding of other people's
perspective and an experience and and
and that involves yeah I mean an
inordinate amount of talking to people
and listening and and and hearing what
people say and also when you're done
writing what you've written
show your work to people who have lived
and say is there anything in here that
sounds like [ __ ] is there anything
in there could you point the [ __ ]
out and I do that all the time I go can
I have AI friends that I can go point to
the [ __ ] and I and it was terror
it's terrifying - right outside your
perspective because you do have the
world's can comment on it right and and
if you make a mistake you you
here about it right and I instead of
shying away from that which I I'm
fearful a lot of craters have been doing
I've been eagerly investigating outside
in my perspective even more so and I I
just put out a book this year called
pearl there's a few books coming out
through jinx wall that DC and one of
them literally has characters based on
me and David it couldn't be more like
our perspective of the universe and then
there's another book called pearl that's
about a tattoo artist that works in San
Francisco who's an american-born
Japanese girl who is on albino who
couldn't be less like my perspective and
it's filled with things that have been
just poured over cliche just like Kooza
stories they're just filled with the
worst cliche in in American culture
right sorry I said let let us let it let
it let us create a scenario for
ourselves where we are embracing all of
these terrifying things for for writers
and and I put out this book in in a
blind terror
I literally the nicest book came out I
literally I said I I can't [ __ ] sleep
I can't believe it I can't believe I put
out a book every week of my life for
last 27 years and I'm literally like
sweating about about this because
because I'm so scared and then literally
went on Twitter and I saw a tweet from
Arthur Miller that's the best work is
the work that is that close to
embarrassing that is it close to link
that is the only work worth doing and
I'm ISM I got that is that's what I feel
I feel like that's and this is what
you're supposed to feel like so III tell
my students I tell all the writers dive
in go go go look outside yourself and
then guess what when you go outside
yourself and look for all that truth you
find a lot of healing things about your
own life you find a lot of commonality
and then you know that's why we're all
here because we're all connected to
stories like that's this is you know
this is you I you tried to reach out you
wanna you want to tell your story so
connects to other people
and the only reason you can do a way you
can really do that is to reads outside
yourself so well and if I just might
jump in for a second which is I think
part of the reason why there is a there
is pushback is because there are so few
there are so few writers of color in not
just the comic industry but in all of
pop culture whether it's television film
our numbers are beginning to increase a
little bit when it comes to prose but
but really you know it's it's not to
where it needs to be and if there were
more writers of color this wouldn't be
as much of an issue as it is but because
there's so few of us because up until
2016 no black woman had ever written at
Marvel no I think I could be wrong but I
think I might have been the first Asian
American woman to write at Marvel and
that sucks
those numbers are terrible and it really
hasn't improved that much it's you know
it gets better in incremental bits here
and there but because there's so few of
us I think I think that's the reason why
there is there is pushback no I it's
because if if we were like if it was
5050 if there's more of us it would be
less problematic but the visuals just
suck and the lack of structural
diversity within these industries sucks
and I but I do I'm so proud of Kelly sue
because I do think she was the one that
stopped her foot and said it's safe and
and I can I can feel a difference from
the origins of Carroll core to today
that feels like that like there's a
don't you do you feel like it's it's
just shift in a grandly great direction
and voices of people of different
ethnicities and and sexualities finding
their way in comics oh I mean the
numbers are definitely improving yeah I
see it mostly in indie comics I think
it's beginning to trickle into more
you see not as much as I think it's
needed particularly since these are our
platforms they're not just these aren't
just companies that you know have our
favorite characters these are platforms
in which these characters reach out to
masses and masses are affected by them
and their stories and so when you only
have one kind of imaginary influencing
the stories that are being put out it's
very problematic and I think that it's
confusing and confusing and I think that
it's something that needs to be very
carefully examined going forward how
this can be changed and how we can
change these structures within Marvel
and DC because the indie comics are you
know we're like I said it's not great
but we're beginning to catch up more but
how within Marvel in DC we can make
fundamental changes so that going
forward the imaginations aren't that are
producing these stories no matter how
benevolent no matter how well
intentioned aren't so limited yeah my
daughter it's 11 years old and she's so
connected to lumberjanes that she I
caught her taking all 10 volumes to
school every day and it's like just for
her back I'm like you it's one at a time
you don't need all ten but III and I but
I used to do that I used to like okay so
like I might need all of this today I
mean I might need every issue of Captain
America today I'm feeling it right so I
I so when I see and I know it's
anecdotal but when I see like my
daughter on her own not you know just
completely invested in this and this
imagination that speaks so deeply to her
I I feel good about things I feel like
these building blocks are seeing right
now are just gonna explode over the next
few years also even the amount of
college classes the amount of people
that are teaching and learning has
altered the way comics being made in a
very excellent way I think so we have
one last question and if you brought
something by the way to sign then after
this question is asked and answered you
can come bring that down so you will now
have to create a question vetting that
just sums it all up bring brings it all
home it's all in you man
this was very cool thank you very much
and I had one question but Marjorie you
said something I thought was pretty
interesting too so hopefully both quick
but you said that sometimes when you
write it feels like you're somehow
predicting the future do you ever feel
do either of you ever feel when you're
really creating something that reality
somehow bends to what you write rather
than a prediction it's actually a
creation of reality that's a good one
that's a really great question the
second part of this is it does I'll be
thinking about that for the rest of my
life but go on ya know because you know
think everything's awesome you know when
you're so immersed in like these this or
these worlds that you create and you
know there's a there's a lot of themes
that come out and I think especially in
comics and one of which is people die
and they come back and so given that
you're immersed in these worlds do you
believe in death do you believe in
destiny yeah I was died I really believe
in it yeah yeah I was told I wasn't
leaving the hospital I was a yeah III do
I do believe it no but I know that
people in comics get frustrated by the
by the resurrection but I think it's one
of those things people you can't have in
the real world so it's the only place
you can get it is in comics it is I know
there's a cheap drama to it but there's
also a profound way to do it that's so
exciting and beautiful and and a lot of
us have really loved those and a lot of
creators have gone out of their way to
create that moment of that thing you
can't get that person back in real life
but you know what we can get them back
here so let's do that's how that moment
we can't have anywhere else so it's it's
more about that that you know that the
the wish fulfillment
then then
than baloney you know and sometimes
they're the same thing
so I was raised in a Buddhist Christian
household so I've got like a mishmash of
beliefs but you know I'll tell you
something
as far as death goes but but as far as
do I bend reality I mean I gotta really
think about that I will tell you that
when I'm in my zone and I'm listening to
super loud music to get into that place
where I can just release myself and not
and not self-censor I it's weird and
it's gonna sound really boo boo and UAG
but I do feel like there's a part of my
consciousness that that goes somewhere
else like and I can't explain it any
better than that but it's when I'm
typing really fast and I don't write
longhand because if I did that it's too
slow yeah okay so something about typing
where I can my brain can just relax and
just things just flow out and it's kind
of this really wild sensation that's
beautiful and I don't I don't feel like
I tap into it as much as I want it's
almost drugged yeah it bet you feel like
you you're often writing what you wish
was happening like you're not even
consciously like you're writing like you
I wish the world was better I wish the
world was kinder I wish the world was
more understanding so you write that
world right and and my conversations
between people are often conversations I
wish was happening versus the
conversation that I witnessed right so
by doing that you're often putting
energy out in the world yeah that and
that that you're you're that you're
wishing and then people are reading it
and then somehow they're reflective of
it and then they may behave better like
the you know enemy like you definitely
feel like you're in charge of your
energy that you definitely feel like I'm
in charge of the energy I'm putting out
in the world and it does I I certainly
looked at my Twitter feed as saying like
this is this should reflect me more than
it reflects you know others and and so
my Twitter feed is all about inspiration
and lifting other Creators up because
that's literally where I want my energy
to be produced so and and and so you do
after after many years I guess it takes
a while but you do feel like the energy
I guess it's because I this is the first
I've ever felt like there's younger
creators they grew up reading my stuff
like who told me now like I never had
that before so like like I feel like oh
my energy is is I should keep doing this
this is this is positive energy and
hopeful energy is is is good thing to
put out in the world so that that's it's
more that than being like a soothsayer
more more wish fulfillment
[Applause]